has your perspective about
um your song Choices change for instance
need you now as about as a quarter after
one hour but I need you one of my
favorite lady songs or bartender yeah I
look at your songwriting and your songs
differently or no I think songwriting
moving forward probably I won't go there
as much I'm not saying I wouldn't have a
reference I mean some of my
some of my uh best songwriter friends
that are sober say they write better
drinking songs now that they're separate
than they did when they were drinking
but
um I've had a lot of people ask they're
like are y'all not going to do like
bartender I was like of course we will
that's a part like just because I'm
going through this doesn't mean that
anything there's nothing wrong with
drinking yeah there's nothing wrong with
saying these songs and that was a big
part of my life and uh I mean nature now
was a lot of truth of where I was around
that time you know before writing that
song you know and so we've all been in
that place yeah exactly